Balenciaga just wiped their Instagram
page
okay if this were just nothing
don't you think Balenciaga would just
sort of move on oh no big deal they
wiped their Instagram page they've
issued
a major apology that's not the only
thing that's featured on their Instagram
page and here's what they say
the first campaign
the gift collection campaign featured
children with plush bear bags dressed in
what some have labeled BDSM inspired
outfits
just put a pause there it's not what
some have labeled BDSM outfits it's it's
BDSM outfits I don't know how else you
would describe it
would you say they're dressed up like
Cowboys no are they dressed up like
bikers no
they're wearing like weird leather chain
stuff but it's clearly a weird sex thing
our plush bear bags in the gift
collection should not have been featured
with children
this was a wrong choice by Balenciaga
combined with our failure in assessing
and validating images the responsibility
for this lies with Balenciaga alone okay
so they are saying
they're they're trying to weasel out of
it a little in the beginning some have
called it a BDSM thing but then they're
saying look this was terrible this was
terrible this shouldn't featured kids we
shouldn't let this go through we're
sorry it's our fault we're sorry we're
sorry we're sorry
so I don't want to hear oh you you
conservatives are blowing this out of
proportion Balenciaga admits this is a
weird creepy
pornographic child featuring s m having
weird sex thing but then they go on they
say the second
separate campaign for spring 2023 that's
the one with the child porn case being
featured which was meant to replicate a
business office environment included a
photo with a page in the background from
a Supreme Court ruling United States
versus Williams 2008 which confirms as
illegal and not protected by freedom of
speech the promotion of child
pornography all the items included in
this shooting were provided by Third
parties that confirmed in writing that
these props were fake office documents
they turned out to be real legal papers
most likely coming from the filming of a
television drama the inclusion of these
unapproved documents was the result of
Reckless negligence for which Balenciaga
has filed a complaint we take full
responsibility
accountability for a lack of oversight
and control of the documents in the
background and we could have done things
differently okay
I don't buy it
I don't buy it I always want to give
people the benefit of the doubt I I
strive to cultivate a spirit of Charity
and always seeing the bright side of
things sorry I don't think so once it's
a fluke
twice it's a coincidence three things
four things five things I don't know it
just seems a little bit weird
and we are seeing
lots and lots of evidence that
Balenciaga and the people around
Balenciaga
have a weird fascination with weird sex
stuff and kids
okay I'm just noticing that I'm just
seeing that
and we've got a lot of evidence to back
it up you're telling oh oops actually uh
just as we're getting all this heat for
a weird pornographic child featuring
campaign
oh just oops coincidentally the set
decorator use these documents it's
probably from a television uh drama
probably we're not going to give you any
evidence of that but you know let's just
say it's that and it just coincidentally
the the exact part that's featured there
specifically refers to a child porn case
and yes it's from that notice they say
it's from US versus Williams which was a
case that said that the peddling of
child porn is not protected speech but
in the in the line of that document that
was featured specifically in the
photograph
it referred to a different Supreme Court
decision it was the the Free Speech
Coalition case which actually found that
simulated child pornography is protected
speech
which is a ridiculous ruling from the
Supreme Court but the ruling it was
referenced there was a pro-child porn
case
balenciaga's argument is oh this was all
just accidental
let me tell you something if you most
people have never spent time around a
film set or a photo shoot Etc
nothing is accidental
on a film set on a photo shoot set
especially when we're talking about a
very prestigious very high-end fashion
brand
it's not like you walk up there with a
you know a digital camera and say Okay
click click click okay we got our shots
everything is meticulously set
and when you start pulling on this
thread it gets really really weird
because one of the big stylists for
Balenciaga a woman named Lada volkova
got a lot of press yesterday not from
the corrupt establishment media but just
from citizen journalists just from
regular old people who were looking into
just poking a little bit into the
Balenciaga story and the stuff they
found
well I'll let you judge for yourself
I don't see any way to read This Woman's
Work as anything less than an obsession
with sexualizing little kids in the most
perverse egregious nauseating sort of
way
so Lada volkova was a stylist a very
prominent stylist
worked with Balenciaga for a long time
worked alongside balenciaga's creative
director debna vasalia until 2017.
and people started looking into some of
her other work yesterday so Balenciaga
tries to get ahead of the story they say
a lot of volkova has not worked with
Balenciaga or its team since 2017 she
has in no way participated in the
Brand's recent Instagram or advertising
campaigns that's what valenciaga
spokesman told Newsweek okay but this
woman did work with Balenciaga for a
long time she clearly has had a lot of
influence on the company so Jake Shield
who's a former UFC fighter just starts
looking into her Instagram page
we've blurred out the faces obviously
these faces were not blurred out on her
Instagram
well the first ones that pops up is this
little girl in a kind of really done up
sort of hairdo lying on the on the
ground lying on her side in a sort of
skimpy little leotard
and and kind of smiling in a very creepy
way but with a handout that sort of says
no another one is a child in high heels
topless in a very strange sort of
position
obviously a kind of sexualized way you
can see that from the stiletto heels but
not quite showing the face
another one is a child's bedroom just
covered in Gore and blood everywhere
another one is a little teddy bear tied
up in a sort of dungeon or jail cell or
something like that there's more it
wasn't just these four photos
let's see yeah so then there's another
one of people tied up in like kind of
weird plastic trash bags all tied up in
a weird looks very like some kind of
torture scene another one of a little
kid holding up a skull another one of a
little kid being duct taped and tied to
a chair being made to watch something
we're not exactly sure what the kids
being made to watch it another one of
someone with with
entrails pouring out of the the
midsection
and there's more images
so then there's an image on on this
Instagram of just a satanic scene of a
pentagram with a devil demon looking
person up there and then a kind of
sacrifice on another pentagram so now
we're talking about overt overt satanic
imagery
and we're seeing lots and lots of teddy
bears throughout this person's campaign
this is this is a lot of a lot of
volkova this woman clearly has a
fascination with teddy bears now why
does she have a fascination with teddy
bear so maybe it's just totally innocent
because teddy bears are really cute and
fun and plushy everyone had a teddy bear
as a kid fewer people have teddy bears
as adults but it's her kind of lying
around with teddy bears walking around
with tapers and then there's one of a
teddy bear doing a sexual act that's
really really weird so all of this I'm
not sitting here telling you
that this woman is
some kind of witch you know controlling
the Balenciaga campaign
not telling you she's not I mean there's
overt satanic imagery here in weird
child sex stuff but then something
that's really really weird I'm not the
first person to discover this someone
called my attention to it and I looked
it up tried it myself
when I don't know how to explain this
I'm not making any allegation I'm just
observing this okay I'm just noticing
you type into Google translate Latin to
English
so Latin
the universal language right it's
supposed to be the main language of the
world it's the language that when I
attend Mass that's the language that
it's in but it's the language that was
the universal language until very very
recently
you type in ba
from Latin into English you get nothing
just says ba ba because ba is not a
Latin word then you type in a second
word Len ba Len what's the English
rendering ba Len because Len is not a
Latin word either balenci
violin C again you just get bottle and C
because there's no Latin translation of
that because those are not Latin words
but here's where it gets really weird
you type in ba Len C Aga
and then the English translation is do
what you want
I'm not making any accusation I'm not
even speculating I just don't do what
you want the thing that's really weird
about that is
do what you want is the Commandment of
the satanists this was the Commandment
of Aleister Crowley do what thou Wilt is
the entirety of the law that's what he
says that is that is the satanic
commandment going back to the Garden of
Eden do what you want Eve come on you
shall be as gods do do what you want
now when you look on Google Translate
it says would you like to translate this
from hausa which is some African
language but it's not translating it
from housing that's not what it means in
housing when you click the translator
from house it gives you a different
translation
I I have no way of making any sense of
this
other than to observe
that there's something weird about
Balenciaga and we know it's not just a
coincidence and we know it's not just
the Republican reaction the the the
pouncing
because balenciaga's taking this very
seriously Balenciaga is wiping their
Instagram page
apologizing immediately for the campaign
taking legal action against the people
who are creating the campaign
and then you look into it and it's
it's just all this
overtly satanic imagery
you can't write off this stuff as a
crazy conspiracy theory you certainly
can't in a world post Jeffrey Epstein
okay
because post Jeffrey Epstein we know
that there actually is an elite cabal of
pedophiles who who have a whole island
who would go to the island and do weird
sex stuff with kids that you can't just
say well you crazy tin foil High
conspiracies we know that happened there
are court documents about it
and yet we still don't really know who
the clients are we still don't have the
little black book no one's really been
held accountable for it Jeffrey Epstein
got Jeffrey Epstein
delay and Maxwell is getting some sort
of sweetheart deal but what about the
clients
and why why does it always seem to come
down to weird
satanic stuff
you notice this now you might say well
this this designer woman for Balenciaga
she's just ironically
worshiping the devil and putting up all
this imagery the the fact that Google
translate I assume someone just went in
and kind of tinkered with it it's a kind
of weird joke I don't know how else to
make sense of that translation
to and to make it the satanic
commandment that's maybe it's just a
kind of a weird ironic joke or so I
don't but the thing is you can't worship
the devil ironically
you can't do anything ironically for too
long if you do if you if you behave in
an ironic way for your whole life then
it's just sincere then it's just Earnest
that's just what you have done
and when you worship Satan ironically
when you just sort of do what you want
that's a lot of the Satanist says we
don't really believe in the devil we
just do what we want
right that that is worshiping the devil
that is it it's that line from I think
it was baudelaire it says the finest
trick of the devil is to convince you
that he does not
exist
[Music]
[Music]